اذا رشقه صاروخيه كما يبدو من النوع بعيد
المدى نسبيا
انطلاقا من الصوت
والارتفاع وحتى طبيعه اندفاع هذه الصواريخ
وهي نفس الزاويه التي يتم التركيز عليها
وهي المناطق الشماليه الغربيه
لقطاع غزه
وبالتزامن اطلقت ايضا ربما قذيفه او
قذيفتين صاروخين صاروخيتين باتجاه الشرق
هذه المره الان نستطيع ان نرى ان صاروخا
واحدا من القبه الحديديه اطلق الان في
محاوله لاعتراض هذه الصواريخ ولكن يعني
حسب العين المجرده فانه جاء بعد ان تجاوزت
الصواريخ هذه النقطه التي انفجر فيها
وبالتالي الان استمعنا الى صوت الانفجار
ربما لهذه القذيفه الصاروخيه التي اطلقت
من القبه الحديديه وهي بالمناسبه قذيفه
واحده اطلقت حتى الان في مقابل اربعه
صواريخ اطلقت باتجاه هذه الاهداف المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه لقطاع غزه وكما يبدو
بانها ذاهبه الى اهداف ربما تكون بعيدا
نسبيا على قطاع غزه لا ندري بالتحديد ولكن
من شكل هذه الصواريخ وقوه اندفاعها وحتى
ارتفاعها من قطاع غزه يعتبر
هي ذاهبه باتجاه او نحو اهداف
الان
غاره جديده
في المناطق الجنوبيه